we want to start with something that
happened not long after we went off the
air on thursday it was a social media
post from josh gordon who said i take my
mental health very seriously at this
point to ensure i remain able to perform
at the highest level i've recently felt
like i could have a better grasp on
things mentally with that said i will be
stepping away from the football field
for a bit to focus on my mental health
that echoed a statement that he issued
back in july when he didn't join the
browns who were his team at the time
at the start of training camp
now
what happened yesterday
not long after that statement was issued
nfl media reported that josh gordon is
facing another indefinite suspension for
violation of the substance abuse policy
and by the middle of the afternoon the
nfl had confirmed that indeed josh
gordon is indefinitely suspended
and
i i admire him for being open about
mental health issues but the reality is
when he was saying he's stepping away
for a little bit the reality is josh
gordon knew he was stepping away for a
lot longer and maybe for good even
though you can have an unlimited number
of indefinite suspensions where you're
gone for at least a year and then you go
through the reinstatement process and
come back there is a point where
you're just not going to try to come
back there is a point where if you come
back you're going to be 30 32 34. and
for gordon he's getting closer and
closer to 30. he was a second round pick
in the supplemental draft back in 2012.
he has not played a whole lot of
football when he has played he has
played very well
he missed two full seasons 2015 and
2016. before he came back for the end of
2017 he was with the browns everything
was fine until that moment right before
training camp the league ultimately
cleared him to return a few weeks in
and now josh gordon out joining
martavius bryant another guy who had a
prior suspension of more than one
calendar year he was suspended
indefinitely recently by the league and
the problem with this is
because it's all
also protected by the confidentiality
provision in the substance abuse policy
we really don't know what it is that
causes
this suspension and and i've had a sense
this year that maybe the nfl is working
with these players more than it has in
the past because the way the policy is
written if you have an indefinite
suspension and if you're reinstated one
false move and you get another
indefinite suspension with a minimum of
a year one
violation that's it
and i just i think that the league has
been a bit more lenient now because
there's no transparency here we don't
know how lean in and we don't know
whether they're being more lenient with
some than they are with others i've had
at least one person point out to me hey
randy gregory the cowboys defensive end
he's had issues since he's been
reinstated why isn't he indefinitely
suspended and does it become a
competitive advantage issue where the
nfl is maybe a little more lenient with
one
than they are with the other it's a fair
question because we have no way of
knowing what it is that gets the nfl to
say enough's enough you're back on
indefinite suspension you can apply for
reinstatement in one calendar year but
for now gordon we know suspended and by
the time that it's finalized that means
either waived his appeal rights or he
filed an appeal and the appeal was
processed and the appeal was
unsuccessful either way once it's
official that means it's done no further
recourse and we will next see josh
gordon at the earliest
as the 2019 regular season comes to a
conclusion but you know the other
reality here is
the way the substance abuse policy is
written
it kind of suggests that the
commissioner has 60 days after the
application for reinstatement to issue a
ruling but when you look at it carefully
and i've had the league confirm this for
me this came up a couple of years ago
with alton smith
there really isn't a deadline for making
a decision so who knows
if and when josh gordon will apply for
reinstatement who knows if and when
he'll get reinstatement you can actually
apply 60 days before that one year is up
so in theory you get a decision right at
the time the year expires and you can
come back so in theory could he rejoin
the patriots next year for the last
couple weeks of the regular season in
theory yes as a practical matter
it may not happen i would not i would
not
feel confident predicting with any
degree of certainty that josh gordon
will be back either late next year or
anytime after everything he's been
through and we we support him we feel
badly for him and i think that the
policy itself that's at the core of
these issues
the policy which which polices what
players do on their own time and it's
not performance enhancing drug policy
this is substance abuse policy this is
recreational drugs and some of these are
legal some of them aren't depending upon
where you are but these are things that
are done
typically privacy of your own home
typically away from the facility i mean
it's one thing if a guy's smoking a
joint in the locker room okay i could
see why a team would have a problem with
that especially in the state where it's
still not legal to do that but
for things that happen in the off season
during those months where you're not
even at work at all
there's a
there's a question of how far any
employers should go when it comes to
reaching into the private lives of their
employees and i think the nfl is
realizing that
they're not helping themselves by taking
talented players and saying you're not
allowed to play for something completely
unrelated to anything you ever did at
work why do you want to deprive yourself
of talented players like josh gordon
martavius bryant
justin blackmon how good could he have
been
as an nfl player if he hadn't washed out
altogether because he couldn't comply
with a policy that dictates what people
do in their private lives so i think the
nfl would like to
get out of the marijuana and substance
abuse policy business and i think when
the next cba is negotiated that's going
to get thrown into the stew of issues
where there are you know different
requests and concessions and you
ultimately have a new cba i think the
nfl is going to find a way to back off
of the marijuana policy and the
substance abuse policy not completely
but i think what they'll do is they'll
soften to the point where there's
something on the books
that as a practical matter is never
enforced with draconian measures like a
suspension for a full year tom curran of
nbc sports boston is going to join us
coming up in about an hour
and curran's attitude about this from
the patriots perspective seems to be
very pragmatic that the patriots brought
josh gordon in knowing full well that
this was potentially a limited
engagement they gave up a fifth round
pick will get a seventh round pick back
because they didn't have a six round
pick to trade for 2019 so they knew what
they were giving up they knew what they
were getting and i think that they
expected that anything
beyond that would be
would be it would just be you know a
bonus and just anything he does
positively is a bonus because the
patriots at the time did not have a
receiving core they felt good about and
there was one point during the trade
negotiations where
the
the patriots weren't going to get a
seventh round pick back if josh gordon
was active for ten games and ultimately
the patriots got the seventh round pick
back with no condition but that 10 games
it just that kind of gives you an idea
of what the patrons are kind of hoping
to get out of the guy hey if we get at
least 10 games out of this guy then it
was worth it and they got 11 games out
of them the problem is as they work
toward the postseason the guy who's been
their most productive receiver from a
yardage standpoint with 720
he's gone and now they have to pivot and
focus and hope that others can step up
and we'll see if they can beginning this
sunday against the buffalo bills stats
you got a question strictly from a
football standpoint mike wouldn't the
patriots have been better off if they
had just paid brandon cooks
well they didn't want to pay brandon
cooks they don't like to pay players
that kind of big money value and they
got a first round pick in exchange and
look i so that was just all so bizarre
that brandon cook's first round pick of
the saints and after a few years saints
get a first round pick to trade him to
the patriots after one year patriots get
a first round pick to trade him to the
rams and i look brandon cooks is not
tearing it up with the rams is he i mean
he he's well when we if we list the top
five receivers right now brandon cooks
isn't going to be on it so he's better
than anybody new england has well that's
yeah that's not a bad point that's not a
bad point but you know they think that
their system makes it go and they try
what they try to do in new england and i
know that every once in a while they'll
make a splash on the open market and
sign us stefan gilmore to a big contract
but what they typically do
is they try to pay less
because they want to have
depth that isn't undrafted rookie or
fifth rounder who's been bouncing around
the league they want to be able to have
veteran backups that they pay good money
to they want to have a solid middle
class of players so that when the
injuries happen the guys who are
stepping in are good enough where
they're almost as good as the guys who
were injured and if you start paying
brandon cooks market value and mark and
look at that look at the contract
brandon cook's got from the rams that
the patriots were never going to do that
and it's not the way the patriots do
things but yeah now they're stuck with
julian edelman chris hogan
philip dorsett cordell patterson and
matthew slater who last caught a pass in
2011. that's your five deep receiver
and and i want to go back to sunday 4th
and 15th the last play from scrimmage
when the patriots were trying to force a
tie against the steelers
josh gordon wasn't on the field and
offensive coordinator josh mcdaniels
explained earlier this week well he'd
been in on prior plays and he was tired
and we put cordell patterson out there
instead and there was no ulterior motive
starting to think there was an ulterior
motive i started to think the patriots
the team always knows that this is
coming because what happens is the
league informs the player and the team
that the suspension has been
initially decided and then the appeal
process unfolds so there is a period of
time where the team is aware i think the
team knew it was coming and the team was
beginning the process of detaching from
josh gordon
because i look at it this way yeah they
would have loved to have beaten the
steelers but if josh gordon has 150
receiving yards on sunday against the
steelers now all of a sudden he's gone
that has a different impact on the
psyche of the team
so you put cordell patterson out there
instead of josh gordon because you know
what
cordero it's going to be you
starting next week against buffalo it's
going to be you week 17. it's going to
be you in the playoffs because we know
josh gordon's not going to be here and
at a time when
i was believing that the patriots really
could pull it together because of the
extensive playoff experience they have
to not have josh gordon it just puts
more pressure on tom brady and these
opponents in the postseason they're
going to smell the blood in the water
they are going to come after brady if
there's if there's a belief that brady
is shying away from contact there's
going to be more contact if he's getting
rid of the football faster than he used
to because he doesn't want to take that
hit if his internal clock is sped up and
even if he's not being pursued by a
lineman he throws the ball sooner than
he would have because he's he's used to
having less time
that's
that's the kind of thing that they can
make it even harder for the patriots to
advance cooks by the way 72 catches 1107
yards three touchdowns that's that's
that's good that's very good
um
i don't know that you have those numbers
in new england and ultimately bottom
line and and look at look at the
criticism of the rams stats and this
came up during the broadcast on sunday
night how michael's and chris
collinsworth pointed it out they have
backups who aren't getting it done
because the rams have spent on big name
player big name player big name player
it keeps you from having a second
string
that has guys who can come in and play
and you're confident they can play the
patriots have that second string because
they didn't pay a brandon cooks but they
may be regretting that now i won't
disagree with that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports